hello and welcome to this video playing
p.m. moscow litre yeah and i need a new
line against the Scotch I really do okay
this is not super threatening at least
okay didn't expect that just gives me
the bishop pair why why why why
surprising him or charge if I
immediately tried to refute this it's
tempting it's ready tempting giving up
the dark squared bishop and then playing
a flow that's risky that's strategically
extremely risky 95 is the only thing
that White's position has but we'll see
how dangerous this this will become so i
can go 97 to prevent that or just put
the night here Queenie 5 is also
interesting yeah i think i'll i'll start
with this movie i think this is this i
probably have to do anyway so let's play
it also covers d7 they would see five
ideas
yeah the 925 is the Sun a big question
you know what to do still cannot play it
easily Knight a5 can be interesting if
he goes Bishop g2 Knight a5 is
interesting if he takes it Bishop takes
I'm in this pin and would prevent night
the night to come and see for hang so it
looks like he probably will take no it
doesn't
hmm interesting he's also attacking f7
I'm not sure does he really okay let's
take this first I wonder if he really
can take on sm Bishop c6 he might he
might really take it
I thought neither six was the plan okay
it's not much I mean I wonder if I
should take an idea of sixes okay let's
play the simple the simple stuff never
expect a move here absolutely never I
think not a single one
yeah black is a little bit better here
but it's not clear if I can really am
make something serious get something
serious going here probably not to be
honest
hmm that's interesting he's got a 5v5
maybe I can do this down it takes it I'm
get g3 with the big check
yeah the cast to play Bishop g2 him
check
it's really a bit annoying that I sorry
that I cannot play and something on the
long diagonal because of that discovery
yeah I've come to play him I don't I
don't think this should be any problem
g4 is not the most important porn Ali
anyway nothing check on the 3rd + + b2 I
mean
Plus Bishop d4 if the King moves time
warning check probably don't get down
right it's difficult and i don't i don't
get them
should be two then we'll be three bit
awkward can be won I've got this check
check okay so it's a win after all even
get to promote check check check check
now the other one is made I was stupid
let's let's not make a stalemate here it
would be a bit embarrassing okay yeah
okay winning I don't know it probably
was a driver for a long time but yeah
this is a bit better for black because
of the support structure and the better
bishop but you should win i guess i mean
it's tough to talk to see how to win
maybe c6 king c7 prepare be five yeah i
mean i tried some things with d5 but
yeah this was important that i had this
resource yeah it's a bit better for
black yeah I have some ideas and white
has not much to do no hear hear the
engine gives me a win I wasn't it wasn't
so sure about this Jack I instead of
this i can i can just play for an attack
just is an attack ok this is better but
not sure of it wins all right we should
be too yeah okay we both didn't have
much time I was thinking okay with what
I did this should probably also win it
because I chunky cannot keep the edge
porn yeah okay I'm happy with this game
I think I have defended well at the
beginning i'm not sure i defending it
was a bit bit of a strange position but
i'm quite a play with what happened to
you okay god thanks for watching